we got a voicemail yesterday attempting
to call me out for glaring hypocrisy on
media freedom and to refresh your memory
on Monday I did a story basically
summing up the multi-faceted war on a
free and independent press that Donald
Trump is waging this includes starting
to use the term enemy of the American
people when referring to the media
attacks on individual media outlets as
fake news talking about the possibility
of journalism licenses sending out this
completely whacked-out survey to
Republicans asking push poll questions
about who's the least fair to Trump
who's the most dishonest when reporting
about Trump so I described that on
Monday and then I got the following
voicemail at our voicemail number two
one nine to david p take a listen to it
so trump trashed the media and then you
trashed trump for it but you trashed the
media every show every show you asked
for money because hey independent media
is so much better than the rigged paid
for media right if we had a media that
worked there wouldn't have been a
vietnam war there wouldn't have been a
war on Iraq and probably a dozen other
ones yeah listen these are two separate
things okay I'm trying to think about
how do you even explain this so one of
the things I do on the show is when
there are biased media reports or false
balance and media or incorrect reporting
or whatever I describe it to you I
analyze it I give my critique and I say
many times that if you want to increase
the diversity of voices in media it's
good to in addition to paying your cable
bill or doing whatever else you do if
you do that it's good to also support
independent shows like the David Pakman
show that is not me attacking the
institution of a free and independent
press right these are two totally
different things
Trump framing media as the enemy of the
American people is not the same as me
saying look at the crazy fake debate
that they had on Fox News right these
are two totally different things and I
hope that the reason I'm struggling to
explain it is because most of our
audience kind of gets that yeah
different things Pat it's like two
unconnected things can be true at the
same time yes right that's right it can
be daytime and also cold at the same
time huh it could be day or night it
could be cold or warm and these things
can happen and I guess four different
combinations or whatever the number is
yeah listen that there's my critiques of
independent media of individual media
outlets have nothing to do with my
defense of media as one of the most
treasured and fundamentally important
institutions of American democracy to
the extent that it still exists and we
want it to exist we've got a great bonus
show for you today
a waiter admits that the racist note he
claimed to have received from diners was
fake
the waiter made it up we will talk about
that we will talk about Donald Trump's
new effort to revoke security clearances
of ex-intelligence officials who have
criticized him there's a nice little
idea and I will issue Pat a public
defense of public libraries I believe
public libraries are still an important
staple of the Commons and rel relevant
even in 2018 so that'll be what's more
exciting than me talking about libraries
come on very few things
ww join pakman.com to get access to the
bonus show you can also access it by
becoming a $5 a month or hi remember on
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show